exposer des oeuvres aux rayons
ultraviolets pour y découvrir des
secrets
certains y verront une ressemblance avec
cette scène du film le code da vinci
les experts présents au monastère des
augustines de l'hôpital général de
québec ne cherche pas nécessairement des
symboles comme le faisait le professeur
robert langdon
mais des indices associé à des époques
c'est sûr qu'il ya des vernis par
exemple intitulé à certaines époques qui
vont flux reste et d'une façon plus
verdâtre toujours là ça va leur donner
une idée de l'époque du vernis avec le
travail au lait l'équipe peut donc
observer des vermines la teinte sur des
textures qui se sont estompées avec le
temps l'objectif est de permettre aux
industriels de mieux comprendre
l'histoire de l'illustration religieuse
qui date du xviie siècle et qui étaient
utilisés par les frères et les paris
collet qui ont construit les lieux la
fresque a été découverte dans les années
80 à la suite de travaux au monastère
il est évidemment c'est pas de repeindre
la peinture c'est mais près de lui
donner peut-être une protection qui lui
permettra de survivre encore longtemps
tant pourquoi pas parmi les mots et les
dessins est toujours visible il y à
cette phrase tout haut au point de salut
sans croix et sikhs et quelques autres
éléments comme une couronne d'épinés une
croix et des clous des objets tirés des
évangiles des instruments de la passion
s'est passé des choses qui sont très
réjouissante mais qui font partie de la
spiritualité et de l'histoire du salut
que les récollets célébrer l'analyse de
la fresque qui fait partie d'un projet
plus vaste de datation des plus vieux
espace du bâtiment dont la construction
a débuté il y a quatre cents ans ici
audrey paris radio canada québec